we're talking about cybersecurity today
and how safe people's passwords are what
is one of your online passwords
currently it is my dog's name and the
year I graduated from high school what
kind of dog do you have ever taught
Papillon and what's its name
Jamison Jamison and where'd you go to
school I would just go back in
Greensburg Pennsylvania what school I
hit field area senior high school Wow
when did you graduate and 2009 oh it's
like my cat's name and then just like a
random number okay is he gonna have this
cat for a while yeah she's my childhood
pet oh and what's her name her name is
Jolene Julie so I got password of yours
would be Jolie and then a number yeah
like number one like my birthday
oh when is your birthday June 12 what
you read 195 oh great
so Jolie 612 95 yes got it so you mean
to give my password right now no I
cannot do that but we all want to know
what it is
so we can tell you if it's strong or not
oh my goodness
let me think okay one is Tel Aviv yeah
four six eight and then Israel it's it's
only three but it's you know it's for me
it's strong enough Ireland one two three
four Gemma one two three
spell GE mmm most of them are Italian Oh
beautiful yeah like what's a good
Italian pout for my grandma's name
what's your grandma's name Maria Maria
so Maria is your password oh yeah you
know my password I love this because
it's like no matter how good your
systems are and how strong they are
someone is still gonna go and say
something stupid like that it's got a
clever though because like the the
reporter is not sort of gone in hard and
she's not going just give me your
password right like she socially
engineers them you know like what kind
of dog do you have where did he go to
school and then she eventually gets to
the point of getting out the info she
wants so yeah I thought was pretty funny
now moving on to many other funny things
and many other security things hacking
in kids so this is a really interesting
thing where when we look at how easy it
is for kids to hack into systems you
start to think the web's just a little
bit broken and when you have a look
around at everything that's going on you
can't help but notice that there are
hackers absolutely everywhere and what I
want to show you in this talk is where
we find some of these hackers who they
are what they're doing and we added a
bunch of demos as well so how are they
actually getting the systems and how
easy it is so we're going to dumb it
down to the to the almost scary level of
holy [__] as that's employed so where I
thought we might start is to have a
little bit of a think about how we
perceive hackers because we all see a
lot of news right the whole time
something in the news about someone
hacking something and one of the things
that news outlets like to do is they
like to have stock photos
and when you have a look at what a
hacker is you notice some trends what
are gonna the first trend is that stands
out here its hoodies hackers have
hoodies number one number two there is a
there's a lot of green screen a lot of
binary going on hackers like binary
believe it or not and we see this trend
played out over and over and over again
now recently there was there's a little
IndieGoGo project launched for a
security in a box project called Cujo
and you plug Cujo into your home and it
repels hackers like magic they've got a
little bit of a clip that shows you how
it work you may not know it but you've
probably already been act thousands of
hacking attacks occurred each day how do
we know he's a hacker hoodie right
exactly
and he also has us a guy you notice also
that there is some scary music just to
set the scene the other way we know is a
hacker is he's got green text on the
screen that's a very important giveaway
but there is something kind of odd about
what he is doing on the screen and if we
if we zoom in and we go all CSI enhance
on one of the the shots there it's like
he's hacking in a browser right because
there's a browser chrome there's an
address bar there and I saw this awhile
back and I thought well this is this is
really curious I must figure out how
this is done and I figured it out and
I'm going to show you and your kids how
to do this as well so what you do is you
jump over to a web browser and you go to
this website called hacker typer dotnet
okay now when you're on hacker typer
dotnet what you do is you start to match
the keyboard like this now this is
awesome but it gets better because what
you do is while you hack your way and
then you say look I'm like I'm hacking
the Pentagon or something like that
hacking the Pentagon ah damn it I didn't
get in and then what you do is you hack
a bit more let's try this again I think
I got it I think I got it
kkkkk yes when hacker typer dotnet
endless entertainment and that is
actually what they used in the Kudo
video too
convince you that you need the security
in a box product inside your home to
keep the hackers away I wrote a blog
post last week or a zoomed-in and said
here is the code from hacker typer
dotnet here is the code from Cujo so
that's that's an interesting approach on
their behalf they are also doing things
like there's a guy on a Mac with a
screen capture that's available on
google images of a Windows XP BOK with
fakes antivirus Cujo will stop that so
that's how how easy it is to start
hacking now in reality most of the time
when we see these hackers they're more
like this this is anonymous regrouping
some of them have hoodies this is more
likely going to be the people that are
breaking them any of these systems
making names for themselves on the news
and what we end up saying once they take
off the mask when the hoodies and all
that sort of thing is there more like
this guy Ryan Cleary so he was part of
LulzSec and around that sort of 2011
period they're actually quite successful
breaking in the stuff did a lot of
social engineering these guys very
effective social engineers kids are very
good at pushing your buttons and
twisting you do well those of you her
parents know what I mean so Ryan is here
at 19 and he's in court with his mum
look at his mum she is pissed
not just him there's Jake Davies as well
he was also part of LulzSec his mum's
not really impressed either out there at
court getting busted for breaking into
stuff didn't work out real well for
their mind you there in the UK worked
out a lot better for them than the guys
in the US who end up facing charges
pretty much the same as if he'd gone and
killed a bunch of people US has gone
kind of nuts with how they treat hackers
so there's these guys and this is often
who's breaking the systems and we see
this pattern play out time and time
again another good example of this was a
talk talk last year so Talk Talk is a UK
taco so I think like Optus Telstra that
sort of thing and they got broken into
and they had a lot of their data stolen
and just after it happened there's a lot
of press and they
a bit in the news with detective came
out and said we think it is Russian
Islamic cyber jihadis which is
terrifying right it's like the scariest
thing you can is anyone here Russian no
good it's a scary thing thinking about
it's not that I don't like Russians it's
the accent right so they think they're
going to be able and then of course
anything that's in Islamic Jihad he is
going to be scary at the moment and
anything cyber makes it even scarier in
reality the only thing they really were
was kind of cyber because it turned out
to be a 15 year old kid in his bedroom
in Northern Ireland you assume in his
bedroom because where is he gonna be
right wait 15 years old hacking into
stuff so this was curious
fifteen-year-old he exploited a single
injection risk talk about sequel
injection later on and show you how easy
it is to actually break into a site at
risk of that heals 15 there was another
kid bit older 16 there was this really
old guy just like 20 break-in and this
is who it was it wasn't Russian Islamic
cyber jihadis it was kids or very near
kids breaking into these systems and
this is kind of a point of the child's
plaything where it is so easy to get
into these systems like the
vulnerabilities are so low-hanging and
the tools to exploit them are so easily
accessible that we see stuff like this
now that's kind of very I guess
childlike hacking was something that's a
little bit at the other end of the
spectrum
don't friend finder now in case you're
looking at this and you're thinking I
like friends maybe it's a social
networking site might be able to meet
some new people you might actually meet
some new people they make it pretty
clear after you sign up what you're
there for there are not many guarantees
on the web not many like this that's for
sure so they are a site which is pretty
much like Ashley Madison in terms of
their intent they're there for people to
have affairs and they had a little
incident back in about May last year and
they got hacked and there's this
security notice
you know the usual thing really sorry we
got hacks evil cyber hacker G Hardee's
yada yada yada
but one of the things that they set in
here there's one line here one sentence
which is underlined the thing that they
wanted to call out to everyone's
intentions to everyone's attention like
the most important thing to them was
that your credit cards are okay it's
like yes your wife knows that you were
having an affair and it would have been
wise you're worried about because we
know after analyzing the data from
breaches like this and Ashley Madison
they're basically all guys and there are
a small number of Fembots imagine that
having to explain UI so I was having a
cyber affair but it wasn't a woman it
was a computer don't worry about it
we know there a lot of Fembots and we
know their fembots because when analysis
was done on the Ashley Madison data a
huge number of the females signed up
from IP address 127.0.0.1 which is odd a
little bit strange so this happened and
people were upset understandably because
they're saying the problem now is people
can find out if I was on this site
looking to have an affair and I thought
that was kind of odd because you can
find out anyway I'll show you how to do
this what you do is you go over to Adult
Friend Finder calm now protip if ever
you do this in a public arena do not
login you may not be invited back again
so we're not going to login we are going
to go up to the forgot password link
because this is where it gets
interesting if we go to forgot password
and we fat-finger the keyboard so just
whack in whatever we liked we answer
this really hard capture invalid email
all right so this account does not exist
which is interesting
I created a research account research
account called NDC 2015 because I did
this last year at not male innate or
calm as everyone say what my litter is
so just in case you don't know what my
only idea is it's kind of Awesome you
going myelinated comm and you can send
an email to anything you like at
bowlinator comm and then check the inbox
so if there's like that you know you
need to register but you don't want to
give him your real email address
you just want to get through the
registration process you can use this
that's my Lenovo comm the thing is
though a lot of sites like Adult Friend
Finder will block mail inator comm email
addresses so what you do is you use at
not myelinated comm and they don't have
that and in fact what man later does is
you'll see they've got a whole bunch of
alternatives such as bamboo get or
comment now this is random - they've got
hundreds of ultimate domains and
obviously that I published them all is
so that people don't build up lists of
what are fake email addresses anyway so
what we do is we go home on that one
I'll go back to here I'm just going to
copy that on the clipboard cuz we use it
at the moment we go here we solve the
really hard capture we go password reset
and it comes back and it says guess what
your email address is correct
it doesn't explicitly say that but it
tells us anyway because there's an
enumeration risk it will implicitly
disclose the presence of an account and
what happens now is you can go over to
myelinate it you can put in that address
and you can go open up the mailbox and
in here we've got the password reset
email and one of the curious things here
is they say another member may have
entered your username by mistake that's
possible
your wife may have been to that not by
mistake as well that's another
possibility so there's an enumeration
risk and the problem with enumeration
risks is that they pose a privacy risk
right because they leak information now
Ashley Madison happened a few months
after so Ashley Madison got hacked in
July last year they had quite a large
number of people that were disclosed
about 30 million plus apt in July and
the hackers said we don't like what
you're doing if you don't shut your site
down we're going to dump all the data
and they provide a little bit of proof a
couple of Records they were legit we
knew that Ashley Madison had been hacked
a month later Ashley Madison hadn't shut
down they dumped all the data
curiously you'll notice just under that
Ashley Madison banner it says over 43
million anonymous members it's not quite
true anymore because we know who 30
million of them are and what they like
to do in the bedroom
and what they credit-card numbers are on
all sorts of other things so actually
Madison
dad had got dumped and in July so before
the data got dumped but when we knew it
was hacked I thought it would be curious
to discover if they will sustain risk
because people saying the same things I
was saying you know look we're upset
because now people can find out from
having an affair so went over the
website and I entered an invalid account
here's one they forgot password page and
I submitted it and it came back and they
had this message and when I saw it the
first thing I thought was well this is
good right because the bold text there
is very non-committal if that email
address exists in our database yada yada
yada you might have an email address no
we're not going to tell you so then I
went and created a research account I do
have a lot of research accounts lately
and and I entered that and I did a
password reset on it so this was a
research account which I now know exists
in the system and said this can anyone
see the little bit of a difference here
right it's very very implicit but the
response is not the same the response is
different and one of the lessons with
this is that if you do want to avoid
enumeration you've got to go right down
to the bit level and actually look at is
this file absolutely identical not just
the body the response headers as well is
there any tell in there that gives it
away so I wrote a blog post about this
and I I suspect they didn't like it
because they fixed it straight away like
next day bang problem solved obviously
they were getting a lot of attention at
the time I thought okay well that sounds
like a challenge let's do this let's go
and find another way so I went to the
login page
and I thought what I'll do is I'll see
how long it takes to log in so I took my
research account and I knew that email
address existed in the system but I just
fabricated the password 25 times is a
long a talk this was from a very
geographically close location low
latency not much network variance and
play consistently 500 600 milliseconds
as a couple of times here where it's
like the 800 milliseconds line here
milliseconds mark okay then I used a
fake account I saw this you see the
pattern
isn't that interesting why do you reckon
this is some people say it's probably
because when there's a real account it
takes longer to get the data back if
it's taking 400 milliseconds to return
one record from your database you have a
different problem it's not that it's a
very using a slow hashing algorithm and
a slow hashing algorithm is good they
were using bcrypt
so that if they got hacked it would take
a long time to crack passwords and make
it infeasible for a lot of them there
was the issue that they also saw them as
md5 hashes and they all got cracked but
be that as it may they were trying to do
the right thing so by trying to do the
right thing they introduced this other
risk which was disclosure so in a case
like this you've got a hash even when
the account doesn't exist because you
don't want to disclose anything via what
is effectively a timing attack so this
with regards to sort of the kids and the
child's play stuff this is child's play
right to figure out if an account exists
on a site or not absolute piece of cake
all right another popular one another
popular one in terms of really simple
attacks and that's XSS and we still see
a lot of XS s we see very effective XSS
I saw here a message just a couple of
days ago about a vulnerability in Ostrom
light globes because there is persistent
XSS in the database the freaking light
bulbs have got a cross-site scripting
risk so this always happens right it
continues to happen interesting thing
also many people think of XSS is
normally like reflected XSS which I'll
show you in a second or XSS on the
database but there's another type of
Exorcist that a lot of people don't know
about and you can find it by going to
facebook.com hitting f12 going to the
console and I never see this this is
warning people about self XSS and what
it says when you drill down into that
link is if somebody sends you a great
big piece of JavaScript and tells you to
run it in your console don't do it
because what the kids do assume it's
kids is they go hey if you want to see
who's look at your profile run this
JavaScript in your browser
and of course when you run javascript in
the browser you can do just about
anything just about anything so that's a
self XSS let's have a look at real XSS
and I'll show you really briefly how
cross-site scripting works I've got this
website hack yourself first try hunt
comp I use this in a lot of my
Pluralsight courses it's it's a really
good site if you want to break stuff and
not go to jail so so feel free to do
that with this site anywhere from about
40 minutes now onwards
it's got sequel injection risks all
sorts of things but one of the things
that's got is a cross-site scripting
risk now very basically how this works
let's go into a search for like fubar
and when we search for fubar we're going
to see fubar on the screen a couple of
times we get a fubar up here in the top
right hand corner and we also get a
fubar down here in this heading so
what's happening is the web application
is reflecting the input back into the
response which is fine it's nice it's
user friendly there is I'm going to do
I'm going to take my little XSS attack
which is down here I'm going to put that
one on the clipboard I'm going to paste
that in and we're going to see what
happens now is there actually anything
interesting to see here anything out of
the ordinary because something looks a
bit broken we got this broken image
let's look what's going on here so if I
have a look at this image we can see
that the source of this image is
actually going off to evil cyber hacker
comma which is one of my websites I use
that for mostly for evil cyber hacking
stuff and what I've actually done
because there's a query string parameter
there cookies it's taken all of the
cookies in my browser and sent them off
to evil cyber hacker comm and if you
want to see how this works we can drill
into the source code and jump to the end
of the screen Johnny the page and what
we'll see is that my search was
everything from here down to here so
what I've actually done is I've found
the place where foo bar appears in
JavaScript and I've said let's just
close off that Val statement declare an
image the source of the image is evil
cyber hacker com+ the cookies from the
browser append it to the body and then
there's a jQuery selector there too
hide that attack payload would normally
appear in the header the relevancy of
this is that if I can get people to
follow this link and they are logged on
to this website I get their cookies I
get things like their orth cookie as
well which is the thing that keeps them
authenticated I can then create that in
my browser and hijack their session
the thing is though how do I distribute
this because I've got to get this to
people if I can get it to people and
they click it then I've got a problem
so for example let's we'll do an
experiment here let's just tweet it
because then you guys have it like if
you want to see the mechanics of how it
works
why would you log me out okay so what on
that tweeter
because then I'm going to do the tour
fade and all that sort of stuff but
every time I do tweet it and say hey
don't click this link a lot of people
click this link because they cure it
maybe cuz me and they're like you know
it's gonna be something funny isn't it
alright so reflected cross-site
scripting is something that remains a
really easy attack and you might sort of
look at it and go but is this something
that commonly happens right like this
was pretty simple but are many websites
actually at risk so last year I was in
the Netherlands and I saw this guy do a
talk at a security conference the guy
called brenno Deventer is a local Dutch
journalist who does a lot of stuff on
security and he decided to test Dutch
banks and he recorded a video of what he
tested
Automation all the noise is education so
this is reflected cross-site scripting
so on for this link we went to the bank
their bank when you have a look at the
address bar here you can see there's a
little evil off the tile in there
towards the right obviously where
concatenate in a string and then
executing is JavaScript this was
vulnerable Dutch banks now some of you
seem to like this the whole sort of
premise of making banks to the Harlem
shake so I'm going to show you how to
make an Aussie Bank do it so what we do
is you go and you grab this script and
you're going to want to make a note of
line one
troit @hn ford slash harlem shake'
script because after you see this you
will want to do it to Aussie banks as
well so you take that script and we go
and grab an Aussie bank and we'll jump
over to the browser grab something like
NAB and you hit f12 jump into there you
go to the console you paste it in and
you run it
and the really neat thing with this one
is that all the menus actually go nuts
as well now this is fun obviously but is
it actually security risk like are we
worried about the ability to make a
website do the Harlem shake just by
modifying the console because you kind
of want to find it on your own machine
right like is is this a risk do we worry
about this let me give you a
back-to-back demo and then I'll answer
that question so I run this site ever
been pone anyone being in this site keep
your hand up if it was actually medicine
interesting interesting correct answer
too by the way all right so this site is
a data breach aggregation site that that
I set up a few years ago when there's a
major data breach like Ashley Madison or
Adobe or any one of a hundred plus
others I load the data and I make it
searchable and at present there's summer
in the order of 1.3 billion accounts
which are loaded into here if you
haven't checked this you will probably
find that your email address is in there
against Adobe or something else you may
not want to mention now here's the thing
if I hit f12 and I jump into the console
and I paste that same script and I run
it no dancing nothing dances and not
only does nothing dance but we actually
get ourselves a few errors down here in
the console so let's take a look what's
going on what we're getting here is the
first two errors are saying refused to
load and then the first one says refuse
to load stylesheet there's an AWS
address there because it violates the
following content security policy
directive so my site uses a CSP content
security policy and what a CSP allows
you to do is whitelist all the sources
that the browser may load content into
your site from and the way you implement
your CSP is you go to the network tab
you reload this page and we'll go and
we'll look at the first request we'll
look at the response look at the headers
and in our response headers here is our
content security policy so here's the
neat thing a content security policy is
just a response header
which is good I mean it's a really
really simple thing to implement when
you return that content security policy
in the response header you declare I
would like for JavaScript to load from
say the CloudFlare CDN to load from
Google because I've got recapture and
analytics and stuff like that and that's
it if you try to load script from
anywhere else it won't work what this
means is is that if you end up having a
cross-site scripting vulnerability in
your site and you haven't done the right
things in terms of outputting coding all
the usual XSS defenses the safe space
steps up and just blocks it it'll also
block things like running a script block
in your source code it's very
configurable with the CSP you can choose
what you actually want to layout to run
but by default you can't have a script
block because hackers love to put script
blocks on pages socia speeds are really
awesome check them out there's really
good support across crime and Firefox
that's all I'm saying on that some of
the others not so much
however having said that even if the
browser doesn't support it and it sees
this CSP response header it's just so
life goes on just ignores it you're back
where you are having no CSP whatsoever
so at the moment based on Global browser
statistics it's something like 60
something percent of browsers can
recognize pretty much everything in a
modern CSP so they're a good thing to
have all right so CSP is pretty easy now
getting back to the whole kid thing for
a moment
kids love DDoS DDoS is very popular with
the kids and on see Nissen got ddosed by
anonymous in january
why do you reckon anonymous would want
to ddos Nissen they're from Japan Japan
does a lot of scientific whaling so
anonymous decided we're gonna ddos
Nissen and they just started throwing
packet at them until I took Nissen comm
or code or JP or whatever it was at the
time offline it wasn't a very good
reason but they don't need a very good
reason because DDoS is so easy and it
can be hard to trace now what we're
looking at here is a static image of
north and north
these sort of DDoS mapping of what's
happening at the moment now here's the
cool thing you can go off to map dot
north court comm just here and then you
hit f11 as well to put it in full screen
because it does is it kind of awesome
assuming the hotel Wi-Fi actually plays
nice if this loads what are we going to
see is that static map we saw before
animates and there's bullets and things
going everywhere and all sorts of images
showing that this is where DDoS attacks
are coming from because not like very
very slowly there it is
what it's doing is it's showing where
the attacks are coming from where
they're going to and then down the
bottom you get some stuff like attack
types often we see DDoS over things like
SMTP which you'd normally use for mail
you get packets thrown over SMTP we've
got a bit of NTP there the time server
we've got bid HTTP you often see a
pattern in terms of where the traffic is
coming from and going to and that
there's this spot towards the right side
of the map which tends to send a lot of
stuff to this spot on the left side of
the map on a very regular basis
now by no means is this a foolproof
thing and it's a little bit of a pure
pure kind of map but it's kind of cool
like if you've got a big screen in the
office just put this up and people will
walk in and they will think you're
awesome straight away because it is kind
of Awesome alright so that's interesting
it shows us what's going on at the
moment now what I thought I'd do is
let's actually have a look at how people
mount DDoS attacks because you've
probably all heard this before and
thought well this sounds interesting I
might like to know how to mount a DDoS
attack and you can go and get online
DDoS services like this one I'm Christa
and I'm going to promote mappers
professional cheap DDoS service it's
strong fast interested with no time
limit what we do is we take down large
websites large forums game servers and
website blogs can blow your competition
and web enemies away you reach us at sky
Yahoo or MSN at the bottom and we look
forward to in business
where do you start with what's wrong
with that
oh she's such a cute kid she's running a
DDoS service kids do like the DDoS
service in fact kids like DDoS for a
couple of reasons number one is that
let's face it kids like throwing their
toys and that's basically what a DDoS
attack is you know I'm going to throw my
toys and have a tantrum not much more
than that most of the time the other
thing is that very often people use DDoS
attacks to do what Christa just said
blow your web enemies away so what they
do is they play online games right and
when you're playing online games latency
is really really important and they will
discover the IP address of one of their
opponents and they'll mount a
distributed denial-of-service attack
against that IP address so that their
latency goes up and you get to blast on
with the BFG or whatever it is they're
using these days get to blow them away
so this whole sort of premise of of kids
and DDoS you know there are these
services which is one thing the other
thing that we see a lot with DDoS is we
see stuff like this now this is
something a bit different because this
is actually crowdsourcing your DDoS so I
remember DDoS is a distributed denial of
service attack if there's only one of
unis don't have any friends it's just a
denial of service and it may not work
because it's just one of you you've got
to be able to throw enough packets at
your adversary to interrupt the service
they're running or the game they're
playing but if you've got a lot of
friends and you can get them all to play
the same game as you now you're under
something so what we're saying here is
we're seeing calls to arms for one of a
better term and he's saying that the
word like used here quite a bit this is
the low-orbit ion cannon and this is a
free tool available from SourceForge
that became very very popular a few
years ago it was used to great effect
against the likes of PayPal and Visa
when they stopped taking payments for
WikiLeaks because the anonymous folks
got pissed because they thought
WikiLeaks should be able to get payments
get donations got all their mates
together and they started mounting these
attacks now I want to show you how easy
this is but I thought would make it a
little bit more interactive has anyone
here actively done a DDoS attack before
now I didn't think so alright so I got
to find someone here who hasn't done one
what about you because you're just kind
of closest and you didn't put your hand
it you've never done a DDoS attack can
you help me do one yeah come on it'll be
fun let's go all right what's your name
do you know okay we may after this we
may need your address textile number
that sort of thing as well so again are
you from here of you traveled from
somewhere else okay you're from Sydney
now you're going to mount a DDoS attack
and the important thing is that you're
going to do it not me
so I'm gonna stand over here for the
camera now since you've since you're
here in Sydney is there is there like a
football club you don't like or
something like that not sure what about
Trump do you like Trump no a good answer
all right all right so he's what you're
gonna do
we're currently focused on the URL if
you type in Trump calm okay now what
you're gonna do after we hit Trump calm
you're gonna click the lock-on button
next to it now this is a very high-tech
technique what it's going to do is it's
going to resolve the host name to an IP
address okay there it is Trump calm now
what happens is you see we've got
downloads here we've got port method
threads you're going to choose a method
and we're here on the web we're going to
choose like HTTP or something like that
probably fine and then you have to
choose the number of threads so this is
basically how much do you not like Trump
okay so each is
you really like him not you the other
problem is other people's computers as
always weird right okay so we'll give it
a bit of 100 now okay so what you're
gonna do now is it going to go and hit
the button at the top right which says
I'm a charging my laser whilst I stand
back and it goes all right now stop
quick all right good
now here's the thing if all of you did
this at the same time not from this
hotel Wi-Fi but from different locations
spread out around the world you'd send
enough packets to Trump comm to
hopefully have some sort of an impact on
the bastard but who knows but yeah
that's it thank you very much all right
give a round of applause Daisy but you
know here's the point on the most
serious note like how simple was that
now when you're a kid and think the
hectare when you're a kid and you're
sitting at home and you're on the
computer and you've got other mates in
various places you may not even know who
they are apps or social media and
everything and they're saying hey just
open this program plug this in fire
lasers and then go out and play this is
what happens and the really sort of
scary thing about it is we're seeing
kids brought up on charges and getting
records for doing that because it is
malicious right you get enough people
doing it it takes websites offline if it
is PayPal and you take them offline
imagine how much money it cost PayPal
for every minute they're down it's tens
of thousands of dollars so it has
serious damages but the problem is is
that the kids don't appreciate the
consequences of their actions now this
is one way of doing DDoS it's to get all
your mates together and you you sort of
mount this attack but often times people
are actually using services and there's
a lot of DDoS services out there they
can do the whole thing for you and some
of them actually look pretty cool
were you sold as soon as you saw epic
DDoS interface right like that up until
then it looked good but I was like I
mean yeah you might have noticed that
they talked about things like stress
test alright and often you'll see DDoS
services referred to stress tests
because that's what you do it's meant to
stress test your applications so
therefore we are a perfectly legitimate
website please give us anonymous
cryptocurrency and target whoever the
hell you want to now because that's the
way they work they're designed for you
to take the hand your web enemies and
other things like that these things come
and go all the time they stand up the
guys get busted they get records all
that sort of thing and then they
disappear again
so that's DDoS and that's something the
kids love one thing that I'm conscious
of though having kids myself is that
this tiny exposed to Wi-Fi very early as
well anyone have one of these I don't
think it's advisable personally the
marketing material does say that it
comes with a splash guard I probably
still wouldn't do it but the thing is is
that you've got the kid there with the
Wi-Fi device starting to do network a
Wi-Fi things and it kind of makes you
wonder like how smart our kids getting
with Wi-Fi like how well do they
understand it
and do they know how to do nasty things
with it and I went and found a kid who
actually seems pretty switched on lots
of dislike numbers and like signs just
all together which really don't quite
make sense but then when you go get into
it you'll get it and I was like it'll
come clear to me
Betsy set up her computer to pretend to
be the Wi-Fi hotspot as it were in the
cafe so when the victim connected and
they actually connected to her computer
and it was that way that um all of their
data went through her computer and she
was able to see excuse names and
passwords and that kind of thing and and
it's known as a man-in-the-middle attack
or a seven-year-old girl in the middle
of tech apparently now if I'm honest I
am a little bit suspicious obvious video
for two reasons number one bit
drinking cappuccino now look maybe she's
being up all night cracking Wi-Fi I
don't know but it seemed a little bit
odd and the other thing issue is using
why shark is anyone of us why shark
before keep your hand up if you actually
understood it if you've still got your
hand up you're lying yeah because it is
seriously heavy-duty deep packet level
inspection software that for me seems
quite complex so for her I think is
quite a stretch but it kind of does make
you curious right so how easy is it to
actually mount a man-in-the-middle
attack with Wi-Fi so let's have a look
here I'm going to do the way we'll jump
back over to the browser and I have this
little guy here running I have a device
on my desk this really intimidating
looking thing with all the aerials don't
turn your Wi-Fi is off alright this is
part of the demo that's good so what
this does there's a Wi-Fi pineapple some
of you may have seen reference to the
Wi-Fi pineapple before and what the
Wi-Fi pineapple is doing at the moment
and it's been doing whilst I've been
talkin is it's been looking at all of
the networks that you guys have been
looking for and we see these over on the
right so your devices are actually
broadcasting not just these network
names but 200-something other ones which
then scroll down off the screen and this
is what your devices do they keep
broadcasting what you're looking for and
every now and then you scroll down you
find one that people probably would not
want to broadcast but there's a lot of
these ones right so all your devices
keep broadcasting this now do a few
demos and what I'm gonna do while I do
this is just turn on some of the good
bits now if you want to actually have a
look at your Wi-Fi over the next couple
of minutes what you'll see is all of
these network names being rebroadcast
and you look at it like the Wi-Fi here's
crap anyway we're not going to lose
anything right you'll see all of these
one of the things I've configure this
device to do is in networking I've got
Betty's free Wi-Fi and I'll have that
being broadcast here somewhere where I
can actually connect to it
I probably shouldn't start a
broadcasting everything else first but
I'll be able to grab one of the Ryan's
iPhone 6 interesting I'll be able to
grab one of these and connect through
there and route my traffic back through
the device
so this is the interesting thing right
all your devices as you wander around a
broadcasting network things you've
connected to before this is why when you
go home and you walk inside you pull out
your phone you're like magic connected
and then you go to work and magic
happens again except it's not really
that magic it's done by your devices
broadcasting the names that are looking
for so that's why we just saw that big
SSID pool so it's gone let's have a look
at all the names that your device is
looking for we'll put them all in the
pool and then I just turned it on to
rebroadcast the pool now what will start
to happen as people's devices will start
to connect to the pineapple and just for
clarity nothing malicious is happening
you just your traffic's not going to go
anywhere sure says the Irishman anyway
all of this is in order for us to talk
about HTTPS so whilst this thing is
spinning up I'm going to show you a
couple of things with HTTPS as our
traffic is now routing out through here
the problem is is that anything we do
that's over HTTP is now at risk because
all this is about the value of transport
layer security so if we go to an HTTP
address bad stuff may happen if I go to
let's give it a bit of American Express
FBI but what here's one of the
interesting things if any of you not on
this network go to the FBI or go to Amex
you will see a padlock but here's the
thing this is the trick and the problem
with HTTPS is that when you type fbi.gov
into your address bar in your browser
does it go by rate CDP HTTP HTTP and the
reason you see HTTPS is because the
insecure request goes to the FBI the FBI
gets that and it responds with an HTTP
301 returns a location header which
tells your browser to then make a secure
request first request insecure there so
that happens however let's try this ever
been pwned
that loaded let's have a look at why
that is will we'll delve into this a
little bit more let's explicitly go to
HTTP colon forward slash forward slash
enter and now let's look at our network
request now here's what we gonna see
this first request is a 307 at least the
first response is an HTTP 307 and if we
scroll over here a little bit we see it
also went out in 6 milliseconds now all
of us have probably sent enough for this
network to know that nothing's going to
happen in 6 milliseconds right so what's
actually happened is that this is an
internal redirect that 307 does that the
browser is not allowing the request to
go over an insecure connection because
we know that once it comes out of this
PC it's going to get into something like
this and possibly get intercepted and we
do that with the response header as well
so if we go to the first good response
which is this one just here and we go
down here a little bit and we look at
our response headers we're going to see
this one strict Transport Security and
what this header which you'll often see
called STS or h.t.t.h
STS for HTTP strict Transport Security
what it does is it set a max age now
this is about one year's worth a second
and it is saying that for the next one
year this browser may not make an
insecure request it will do an internal
redirect you can also see that I'm also
including subdomains which pretty
self-explanatory there's a little
remaining problem with this though
whatever it is right you gotta get the
first request now this is so-called a
tofu paradigm or trust on first use and
that you've got to get one trustworthy
connection get one trustworthy response
before you can actually get the header
and then have confidence you don't have
security we've got to fix that though
because what we do is we scroll over
here and we do this there's a preload
directive and I got to show you how
preload works what you do I'll put that
in my address bar there I'm gonna go to
HSTs preload EPSA calm which also uses
preload so the connection or gate is
fine and then I'm going to search for
this have I been poned address
I think we got to take out the scheme
there and check eligibility and so it's
here hello Ben point comm is currently
pre-loaded this site is run by the
chromium project and this site allows
you to say I want to have my domain
preloaded into the browser and what
preload means is that for every single
one of your sitting here if you were to
pull out your laptop and go into Chrome
have a look at your HSTs preload list
you'll see have I been poned in there
whether you've been to the site or not
because preload bakes it into the
binaries which means that the very first
time you ever go to have a beanpole calm
even if someone's man-in-the-middle in
your traffic even if you're trying over
HTTP it won't work
which is cool now there are some
conditions required for this so things
like you've actually got to redirect
your traffic all right so they want to
see intent that you do actually want to
go wretches TS you need to use include
subdomains and you've got to have that
preload directive so you can't go and
find a competitor and go I know what I'm
gonna do I'm going to preload them even
though they don't support HTTPS because
they've got to return that header
otherwise it won't work so this is
awesome
and this was a really good step along
the path of HTTPS for everything let's
go back to the pineapple oh boy
so what's happening here is all of these
devices under the host names and they're
connected to the pineapple anyone see
themselves it docks MVP I can see doc
okay there's something about the Mac
books that are for want of a better word
promiscuous well this guy now as I
phoned thank you no sir so this is the
thing Dinesh is up there somewhere the
androids have a bit of funky naming
these devices are connecting to the
pineapple thinking they're connected
someone else
remember this is why I love demos it's
just the random nature of all this stuff
go
so that I mean this is kind of scary
right but the reason I show this is
because it demonstrates how easy it is
to man in the middle traffic and you
could be a seven year old girl sitting
in a cafe with one of these because it
is literally buy it off the internet for
one or two hundred bucks depending on
the model you get plug it in your
rocking and rolling that easy alright so
that is Wi-Fi and I'm now going to
unplug this so it doesn't mess up any of
my later demos or any of your things
alright let's go into here over look at
one more thing now you know this is
serious hacking how buddy very good what
told a little bit about sequel injection
because sequel injection remains the
number one risk on the web today and it
has that status for a few different
reasons one is that it's very easy to
discover sites at risk of sequel
injection every time you see id equals
in a number and you change that number
to something that isn't a number it's a
lot of sites which will then throw an
error which indicates the mais sequel
injection going to show you that works
in a moment the other thing is is that
the impact when you mount a sequel
injection attack is severe it means
getting data out of the system
personally identifiable in fo passwords
it means potentially modifying data in
the system it means potentially running
commands on the host operating system
because you can run things like XP
command shell on sequel server you can't
from sequel server 2005 and newer unless
you're on the commander II neighborhood
and if the web app is connecting to the
database with a command or with an
account that can do that well then you
got a problem the other problem as well
is the ease of exploit and that's what I
want to show today but first of all a
real bit of sort of basic sequel
injection what I want we got a URL like
this it doesn't matter what host it is
ID equals and then we've got some code
that's running on the web server that
does this and we've got this sequel
string and then it's going okay let's
just get the query string we'll whack
that on the end and then we've got a
query like this which is cool right like
we get widget are they number one
and then you change ID 1 to ID 2 and by
the magic that is data-driven websites
you get a different widget easy now what
if we do this because this is not a
number and this makes that command what
do I can happens of that command runs
it's valid syntax it may not break but
it may do this now here's the thing if
this error occurs in the database and
then that error bubbles up into the user
interface and you see this exception in
the web app it's telling you something
about the database and then the trick is
how do I now go and find or run queries
which are going to return internal data
now before I'll do a demo this one more
thing because I mentioned that a lot of
this comes down to how the web app
connects to the database and if the web
app connects with a privileged account
then you've got a problem because you're
gonna be able to do a lot of stuff I'll
show you a little trick just to figure
out how bad this is what you can do is
you can do a Google Doc everyone know
what a Google Doc is this is like a
really carefully crafted Google search
to do stuff like this go and find things
indexed over FTPS that are webbed up
configs because Google indexes things
over FTP and people leave anonymous FTP
access enabled and what you end up with
is all of these sites with FTP enabled
including government sites now you could
click through to one of these and you
could see connection strings API keys
other sensitive pieces of information in
the web door config but remember this is
anonymous FTP enabled so you could also
browse around the site download files
download that file called database top
back because there's a lot of those on
websites and if you're stupid enough to
leave anonymous FTP enabled in read
access probably stupid enough to leave
it open to write access as well so now
other people can modify the site but
getting back to the point about the
account that people connect under what
if we filter this down a little bit
because it's not hacking if it's just
Google searches
and we go and we say let's add an essay
to that and see if anyone's actually
connecting with sa some people are this
password though fortunately is twice as
strong as it was just SA all right so we
know that people are connecting to these
sites using credentials with privileged
access part of the reason they're doing
it is because other people tell them to
and you can go and find tutorials like
this this is a real live blog post from
last year and the reason I'm showing it
is because it's got some really serious
issues and I left a really really polite
comment and they didn't fix anything and
then there's people who've come along
and said thank you this is very helpful
and stuff like this happens so any any
possible problems here take characters
that's good
and this one's curious because as we
scroll down what we see is we see lines
here which are very very good in terms
of sequel this is parameterization which
is how we want to protect sequel
injection attacks so we've got email as
a parameter here and it's added
separately down here so you can't just
change the value of email which then
changes the Select statement and then
down here a couple lines later
the whole thing's appended in line so
but the time you actually get down and
execute the query the database has got
no idea what is query and what is data
you can modify the query imagine my
email address was single quote semicolon
drop table login table connecting with
sa it's going to drop the login table
but what I really want to show you is
how easy it is to actually exploit one
of these sequel injection attacks now
I'm gonna get another volunteer and I'm
going to get the most hacker like
volunteer I can find any this guy you
look like a hacker to me can we get some
help all right now
first of all how do I know he's a hacker
very good yeah what's your name
ari and how are you six we've never met
before have we yes we have all right
maybe one maybe huh
all right let's get Ari to hack this
website all right
no not this website not this website
let's let's go over to this website and
I'm going to go back to here and get rid
of that okay now let's just zoom back in
a little bit so one of the good things
about getting kids to hack is that they
can't go to jail so get them to do it on
your behalf
okay now what I was going to do is he's
going to choose one of these cars and
he's actually choosing a mic here he's
gone for the oh I do like the McLaren's
I must say alright he's loading up the
McLaren's now what are he's doing here
with his hacking attempt is he's going
to go and copy this URL because if he
can copy the URL and we've got a really
bad surface here but I think he's he's
getting that if he can grab that URL
then he's basically halfway there now I
can say Ari is now gone out tough by his
finding havoc and havoc is free sequel
injection software and it's very Mickey
Mouse for one to a better term so what
are he's doing is he plugging in the URL
that he's just copied here and now he's
about two thirds away through he's
always done he's gonna go and he's
hitting the analyze button over here now
what's happening is this software is
going and making HTTP requests to the
website and it's trying to find
vulnerabilities in the site it's finding
the database looking at all that it's
found the database already DB named hack
yourself first they be he's actually
going way ahead of me he's got his guy
he's gonna go get the tables now because
he knows what the database is he's
pulling all the tables out he come all
the tables alright this is all HTTP
requests over the web and now he's gonna
do he's gonna pick a table that he
actually wants to get data out of though
he's gone straight for user profile
that's what I do
good job but he's got to get the caller
as well right so he's going all the
columns are coming out oh this is juicy
now what do you reckon is going to go
for what would be valuable in the
columns are there's good choice yep I
agree oh that and the parcel goods as
well and what's the last thing required
to hack this website and there it comes
well how about that
well done all right and now it is going
and it's ripping everything to shreds
and that is how easy it is to hack
websites now which websites do your hack
daddy's yeah good boy
all right and on that note that takes us
through because that shows how easy it
is to make hacking child's play thanks
very much everyone
good boy yeah we got a bit of time left
if anyone has any questions for me or
Ferrari uh-huh let me know any questions
yeah yeah China so the question was if
you want to block traffic from any
particular geographical area is it
possible you can always do it via IP
address range right because we can
resolve IP addresses to physical
locations but it's a question about
you're trying to do that casually in the
sort of we don't want your streaming
media from the wrong country sort of
thing versus are we trying to do that to
stop a determined adversary because
they're just going to jump on tour and
go through an exit node or VPN out
through another point so you can for a
very low hanging fruit how to do that
Ari how long does it take you to learn
how to do that there hacking
three days three days really good on you
anyone else all right well thanks very
much to come here everyone
Oh